timelines am i right we've all got at
least one but some people like our boy
the hero of time here have three and i
know what you're thinking bandit again
with a timeline video you've already
made like nine of them on the channel
well yes i have but this video is going
to be a bit different from the others
see previously i've tried to explain the
contorted zelda timeline and even
reinterpret it sometimes into something
a bit more understandable but at some
point a person like myself who tries to
explain video game lore has to ask
themselves if anyone else even sees the
same questions i do case in point the
timeline some people don't see a problem
with it at all but i on the other hand
see several so this time i'm going to
try to explain to you just why the
canonical official approved by the word
of god nintendo themselves timeline is
impossible or rather is way too messy to
actually function as a singular cohesive
timeline and hey don't put words in my
digital mouth i love the legend of zelda
probably even a bit more than i should
since i spend my weekends writing
scripts like this one but i'm not too
blinded by my fan hood to admit when
something smells off so let's cut the
crap and get on the same page and if
you're interested in my other timeline
theories behold they shall be linked in
the description below let us begin so
i'm gonna pull a batman right off the
bat and say that if there's even a one
percent chance that any of you watching
don't know what the zelda universe is i
have to take it as an absolute certainty
and as such we shall begin by explaining
it briefly in the beginning there was
skyward sword and zelda and demise and
also link link killed demise and totally
made babies with zelda afterwards then
the minish cap happened then four swords
happened then ocarina of time happened
and noticed that so far everything's
been nice and cohesive and
understandable and all in a straight
line but at the end of ocarina of time
when the hero of time link and zelda and
ganondorf were done with all their drama
ganondorf gets sealed temporarily and
zelda sends link back in time by the
span of seven years this action splits
the timeline into two one following the
zelda that still stuck seven years in
the future called the adult timeline and
the other following the hero of time as
he returned to his childhood seven years
in the past called the child timeline
still with me okay good because this is
where the sauce thickens see there's
also another timeline that branches out
of ocarina of time in addition to the
child and adult ones the fallen timeline
this happens if ganondorf is able to
kill link and that's it no further
explanation don't know when or how but
that's just it that's the other timeline
yep these three timelines adult child
and fallen each extend for a few games
and then just kind of stop and then
breath of the wild takes place after all
of them but not connected to any one of
them so that's the briefest timeline
explanation of the zelda universe in the
world you're welcome now let's start
talking about what doesn't make sense
really there are just three big reasons
why the timeline is so problematic but
let's start with the latest and work
backwards in the first place breath of
the wild's timeline placement is
problematic and if anything gives more
credence to those who would like to
insinuate that the zelda universe
actually doesn't have a timeline but
rather that every game is simply its own
event with no connections to any other
games i disagree with this train of
thought personally since the wind waker
intro kind of blows that entire argument
out of the water when it just so happens
to perfectly describe the events of
ocarina of time's adult timeline ending
even down to saying the hero of time
popped in and out of time itself which
hey just so happens to be exactly what
happened proving that the games do take
place at different points of time and
can and do reference one another this
being just one example and in 2011 the
hyrule historia book was published which
featured the first publicly released
licensed by nintendo official canon
zelda timeline and if you're wondering
if we can really trust the hyrule
historio or any of the dark horse zelda
books check out this video by my good
buddy monster maze in my opinion the
existence of the zelda timeline as a
whole is really not debatable although
it will eternally be debated since
headcanon is a very strong thing but
anyway back to breath of the wild by the
time it released in 2017 it was clear
that aonuma for some reason decided to
be very very vague with its timeline
placement only confirming that it's the
most futuristic zelda game to date even
the in-game evidence for which timeline
it's supposed to take place in is super
vague there are references to all of the
timelines zelda mentions the twilight of
the child timeline there are koroks and
sea salt from the adult timeline and
there are lynels in the location of the
master sword and the lost woods which
only occurs this way in the fallen
timeline with breath of the wild being
so annoyingly vague it's also spawned
countless timeline placement theories
all across youtube some of which i've
even made as i'm sure my veteran viewers
will recall but let's face it the fact
that breath of the wild itself appears
to reference all three while not being
connected to any one of them also makes
one feel that the timeline either won
had some huge merging event happen like
in hyrule wars um or two that the
timeline doesn't actually matter this is
reason number one for why the zelda
timeline is impossible reason number two
i'm not sure if anyone remembers this
but link's awakening used to take place
after the oracle games in the downfall
timeline it was a nice way of wrapping
up the adventure of the link from link
to the past with link's awakening ending
by spoiler alert
link being stranded in the middle of the
ocean a nice mysterious open-ended
conclusion to the hero's many adventures
in the real worlds both in and around
hyrule and even in the fictional dream
world of coho lind island however as
most fans will recall link's awakening
eventually got this adorable clay chibi
ground up remake which we didn't know we
needed that re-released the game to the
public in september of 2019. when that
happened all of a sudden the official
zelda timeline on the official zelda
website appeared to have moved link's
awakening to before the oracle games and
in the zelda encyclopedia which released
in 2017 and was also published by dark
horse link's awakening was also featured
before the oracle games just like that
it used to be here now it's here step
stop stop step step and at the bottom of
the encyclopedia timeline it
acknowledges that link's awakening moved
positions on the timeline and that this
can continue to happen as new
discoveries come to light and also as
the players imagine just think about
that for a second this nintendo licensed
for all intents and purposes canon
encyclopedia of the zelda universe just
told us that the official timeline of
events that links the universe together
can be manipulated canonically based on
our imagination and that's reason number
two reason number three is the last and
biggest and messiest reason of them all
and also one that astute fans of my
channel will recall that i touch on
quite often and that is that more than
breath of the wild's timeline placement
and more than our imaginary manipulation
of the timeline itself the downfall
timeline makes no sense see when you're
playing ocarina of time it's very clear
that in game in universe whenever you
travel forward by seven years into the
future or whenever you travel backwards
by seven years into the past you're
simply fast forwarding and rewinding
along your own original timeline by the
power of the master sword since link was
too young to wield it and had to be put
to sleep in the sacred realm and you
know more lore jargon this is most
clearly evidenced by link's own age if
he was disconnecting from the timeline
every time he time traveled he would
remain his original fidget he would
remain his original physical age
regardless of what time frame he's
currently in so technically speaking the
quote-unquote time travel that takes
place in ocarina of time isn't really
time travel at all or at least not like
we normally imagine it it's just that
link himself goes unconscious while time
passes around him forward for seven
years regaining his consciousness when
he's an adult time still passes normally
we just don't see it now time does
rewind when he places the master sword
back in its pedestal but again since
link himself d ages before regaining
consciousness it can be interpreted as
the same thing happening but in reverse
somehow everyone still with me no okay
great let's continue on the point is for
the entirety of ocarina of time story
there is only one timeline simply being
fast forwarded and rewound the timeline
only breaks into two when zelda uses the
ocarina of time to manually send link
back to his original time frame seven
years ago but because the ocarina
remained with zelda while the master
sword returned with link both time
frames lived on meaning the separation
of these two artifacts is what shattered
the timeline into the original zelda's
adult era on the original lynx child era
and physically it makes sense since the
hero of time was literally removed from
the adult timeline as evidenced by the
wind waker intro and possibly even the
master sword check out this theory for
more info on that but okay you're
probably thinking right about now bandit
isn't this supposed to be about what
doesn't make sense on the timeline
you're absolutely correct because this
is where things do indeed stop making
sense see there's a third timeline like
i mentioned earlier one that is
completely disconnected from the canon
literal physical events that created the
adult and child timelines the downfall
timeline doesn't have to happen and
that's the entire problem with it see
lots of people say the words timeline
and reality as if they're
interchangeable but really they're not
the reason why i'm being such a stickler
about this is because the adult and
child timelines are just that they were
initially one timeline that was
shattered into two by the power of
omnipotent artifacts the events of which
happened canonically and cannot be
debated since you have to refer to the
end of ocarina of time as when zelda
sent link back instead of if zelda sent
link back since it did happen no matter
what however the downfall quote-unquote
timeline is based on the mere
possibility that ganondorf defeated the
hero of time this is not canonical and
can absolutely be debated because you
can't say when ganondorf defeated link
you have to say if ganondorf defeated
link instead of a timeline this is an
alternate reality that unfortunately
branches into other canonical games and
that is precisely why it's so messy
because why stop there why isn't there a
new alternate reality that branches off
of the official timeline every time link
faces a new enemy isn't death around
literally every corner how many hundreds
thousands millions of alternate
realities are out there am i thinking a
bit too much into this probably i need
to stop watching rick and morty but
anyway that miss amigos is reason number
three for why the official zelda
timeline is literally impossible and
with that i conclude my essay what did
you guys think though do you agree or do
you disagree and believe that the
timeline is actually perfectly
functional let me know in the comments
below please consider leaving a like if
you enjoyed the video or just my efforts
into making it and subscribe if you
haven't already for many more to come
huge thanks as always to my bandit crew
who make my day every day and hey if
you're wanting to help out but don't
want to like you know sign up for
youtube memberships or patreon stuff i
just opened a kofi account so feel free
to buy me a coffee if you're feeling
nice coffee is my life fuel that's all
i've got in this one so i hope everyone
has a wonderful rest of your day this is
bandit looking forward to seeing you
next time and signing out
[Music]
you